it's crazy though right you can just
like
take clothes off in a creative way with
some gnomes and make a hundred thousand
yeah I mean there's a lot more to it
than that but yeah what was it what's it
what's the difference marketing like so
with with only
cams I was unusual and that I decided to
do outside of the website marketing I
like post on Reddit right this was very
unusual at the time but like only fans
are structured such that uh they have
almost no internal Discovery whatsoever
so if you want people to come to your
page you have to go out on the external
websites and advertise for yourself
directly very different model and so
this is something that I had already
been doing and already had practicing
and so I think I was like already quite
Advanced like I already had an account
on Reddit that was like seven years old
at the time tons of like Karma that
means I could post in subreddits I
already been on Twitter for years you
know like posting actively so like I
already had like presences on all these
other platforms that really helped with
the conversion Reddit and Twitter Reddit
Twitter FetLife Instagram Tick Tock and
you are still advertising creatively so
like there's like sexuality but there's
also
like creative sexuality yeah and ideas
too yeah like one of the really popular
ones was I like molested myself as a as
a mime were using a uh a one arm through
a jacket and so the jacket looked like
it was
uh the jacket looks like it was alive
and
you know and that one did really well
did you like brainstorm with somebody
and like I recently got to hang out with
Mr Beast and I said uh uh on a session
of brainstorming different ideas
I just envisioned you with like a team
brainstorming all right how about we try
the mime and the molesting things
I don't know it's too too edgy
I wish I think the team was a lot more
fun but no it's just me like I had an
apartment that looked like kind of like
this you know you just sit alone you're
like well that would be a good idea and
I'd seen you should collect ideas over
time right like
um I'd seen somebody doing a version of
the like this this animated hand act
like when I was a kid and I just always
stuck in my head and like one day I was
like I bet I could do that and then I
was thinking trying to think of ideas to
do as a sex worker I was like why don't
I just try that and then it turned out
to be like like a really like quite a
viral hit is there um is there stuff
like you mentioned too edgy like Mr
Beast tries to keep it PG yeah do you
try to keep it PG-13 well with the sex
advertising stuff I mean it's sex
advertising so it's obviously not PG-13
I don't know these ratings what is even
beyond that family friendly it is X like
even though the one that I'm describing
to you at some point like you can see my
boob as a boob is is X her boob is I
guess it's not R I think you can show a
boom yeah maybe X is like if you got
some sort of rhythmic motion going on
maybe that sound but the rhythmic was
actually not
you could have one or the other but you
can't have both you have both that's
when we hit the X yeah okay so
definitely not family I mean with the
sex advertising stuff like guys like
vanilla [__] guys want basic hot girl
you can do something like kind of sexy
and creative like getting abducted by
gnomes or like the self molestation
right but those are still pretty within
the normal boundaries
what do you mean guys like vanilla stuff
I mean most guys like vanilla stuff
what's Vanilla stuff like see how you
talk about fetish
fetishes I think my uh Overton window on
what is vanilla is expanding
quickly after following your work but
yeah I actually have done a lot of
studies on what is vanilla like I've
done a couple different surveys where I
ask people like how taboo is just saying
a knife or like a rating from least to
miss taboo by the way I don't like I
don't appreciate the beauty of vanilla
ice cream you don't it is really good
though
you eat vanilla ice cream I eat vanilla
ice cream yeah I think there's just so
many more options it's like the absence
of creativity I mean if you put in like
some chocolate chips or something
now they already made it more
interesting
um to start okay so what's Vanilla what
and why do guys like vanilla so hot girl
doing hot girl things what like
undressing and then yeah sex the thing
that I found was most successful were
frames where the man was framed as
passive and the woman is active or like
for example uh like oh you know we got
assigned to the same bunk uh at the
breeding school or something or like oh
we're the last people on earth
right or like oh no uh you know I like I
desperately need somebody to like cure
me with this disease and I need semen so
it's like in any scenario where the guys
just like finds himself such that the
woman like desperately needs him for
some reason and he doesn't have to do
much that is like typically one of the
much more successful things like guys
like women falling into their lap what
about the power Dynamic
um so guys are less into power dynamics
than women are and you can do power
dynamics as long as it's like handed to
them some guys obviously some guys are
like very dominant like prefer like
having to work but this is the minority
like if you're trying to do make 100K in
a month and you're trying to appeal the
whitest group of people the most
effective advertising you're not gonna
be making the most money by being like
particularly submissive so on the
camping side that's your uh unlike uh
like uh escorting or just personal
relationships you're trying to you have
an audience
you have like a theater full of people
like with live camming you have a live
camera yeah it's like a live theater is
that freak you out there's just a bunch
of people watching I mean what how do
you feel right now I don't I don't know
their watch because it's not live yeah
that's true it's not live so like it
might as well be like they could be
watching
I feel like there's just the two of us I
don't know and there's like I feel
sometimes I imagine there's a third
person like God usually no no not not
God just I usually imagine
um
either a guy or girl or a couple just
sitting there for some reason like
usually on the beach and usually high or
on some kind of like about mushrooms
just like listening passively just kind
of looking at the sunset that's what I
imagine well that's really good yeah I
think it's useful like when I write my
blog posts sometimes I do terribly but
it's the most effective when I imagine
one person that I'm writing to to try to
explain and like having a high couple
watching the sunset is maybe really
lovely as a calibration I have to say it
is pretty romantic
because I've gotten a chance to meet
couples that listen to podcasts together
I don't know why that seems like
intensely romantic to me because like
because you're not watching TV together
you're listening to a thing I mean I
guess sometimes they watch it but like
you're listening to ideas together
I don't know it seems like you're going
through the same kind of thought process
yeah yeah that's really beautiful way to
put it so it's like you're melding your
thinking is following the same life some
of my podcasts do that more than movies
I think movies give you a lot more
freedom to think about stuff I feel like
your thoughts are aligned and like
especially if the if the podcast is good
like if it's listening to
um like a Dan Carlin podcast about
history that you're like on a journey
together
yeah is there's an intimacy to that